You now have a pretty good idea of how to start working on a new project.
But what's the best way to learn new skills aside from just practice,
practice, practice?
I think Jacques has some ideas but
again he went back to work so we need to bug him again.
>> Heya, so I actually wanted to just mention the awesomeness that
is learning HTML and CSS on the web when you can see it every day.
So if you like something in a webpage, and you want to see how they did it
[COUGH] you can pop open DevTools and actually see how we cut it up.
So if you like something on the audacity website, and
you want to use that motif, or
that design, those type of styles, you can see what we did.
And that's really great, and
not something you can do in a lot of other environments.
So in terms of learning, it's a great place to start.
Because, I mean, that's how I started.
I was looking at how other people did,
how other people coded up their solutions.
How they managed to make something look a certain way and
being able to open it up.
And our DevTools are much better now.
And they will really allow you to dive into how somebody put something together.
So go and check out a website that you find interesting.
You'll, you'll be amazed that, sort of what people have done and
you can learn a tremendous amount from it.